guess who's back
back again
rob is back with beyond omega level that
was a terrible intro
[Laughter]
that was an awful intro what's going on
guys this is rob and we are back yet
again with another installment of our
beyond omega level series and today
we're talking about a character that is
beyond omega level in an unconventional
way which i'll explain as a video goes
on but as you can probably tell from the
title of this video we are talking about
none other than deadpool so deadpool was
created by fabian necessa and rob
liefeld and first appeared in new
mutants issue number 98 in 1991. now
deadpool's real name is wade wilson
which is definitely not a rip-off of
slade wilson just like the name deadpool
is not a rip-off of dc's deathstroke but
regardless we don't know much at all
about deadpool's origin as a lot of his
past remains a mystery we don't even
know for sure if wade wilson is his real
name or just an identity he assumed
after being hired to kill someone named
wade wilson and then taking his name
after he completed the job all we know
about deadpool is that he was a hiring
mercenary and that he had contracted
brain cancer which prompted him to
volunteer for an experiment conducted by
the weapons plus program that was
attempting to replicate wolverine's
healing factor now the experiment
succeeds in curing wade's cancer but it
has devastating effects on his mental
state and results in him becoming insane
he escapes the weapons plus facility and
begins operating as a mercenary once
more this time calling himself deadpool
a name he gave himself which was
basically modeled after the betting pool
the weapons plus employees ran to
determine which test subjects would die
first now getting into deadpool's powers
he is capable of a lot of things and one
has to wonder how it is that deadpool
was able to just amass such incredible
skill over the course of his time well i
could tell you exactly how he managed to
do it deadpool masked all these skills
by using skillshare yes brand deal time
so skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
where you can explore new skills develop
existing interests and get lost in
creativity now one of the questions i
get asked all the time by you guys is
how i edit my videos well there's
actually a course on skillshare by a guy
named jordy which is amazing right it's
called video editing with adobe premiere
for beginners i mean this series is
phenomenal right it covers everything
from giving you an understanding of like
the layout of premiere pro how
everything works going into like basic
editing transitions text and graphics
speed ramping which is something that i
absolutely needed help on so thank god
he had this video but there are all
kinds of courses on skillshare that you
can take that can help make 2022 a year
of new learning growth and connection
through creativity so the first 1 000 of
my subscribers of you guys the raw core
who click the link in the description
we'll get a one month free trial of
skillshare so you can start exploring
your creativity today
but getting into deadpool's powers his
primary power is his incredibly powerful
regenerative healing factor that he
possesses as a result of the experiments
run on him by weapons plus in fact
deadpool has arguably the strongest
healing factor in the marvel universe if
we take funeral for a freak into account
he's way beyond wolverine the incredible
hulk or anybody else if we leave out the
story line of funeral for free then he's
every bit as strong as wolverine maybe
even stronger and perhaps even on par
with the hulk and to back this up
deadpool has some pretty insane healing
feats he can recover from nearly any
injury he sustains including multiple
instances of regrowing limbs
regenerating all of his skin regrowing
all of his bones and reforming after a
virus melted him to a puddle he survived
multiple decapitations and
dismemberments nuclear explosions and
has come back to life after being killed
countless times he's even been reduced
to a pile of ash and is alive again the
next day finally deadpool is resistant
to nearly any poison and immune to
practically any disease which in the
year 2022 can basically make him someone
beyond omega level in and by itself now
in addition to his healing factor
deadpool is a skilled marksman and an
expert in hand-to-hand combat he's also
proficient with a number of weapons but
most frequently wields a pair of katanas
in addition to the various firearms and
explosives he always seems to be
carrying but the most unique
characteristic deadpool possesses is
that he knows he's a character in a
comic book so he frequently breaks the
fourth wall now this is most likely due
to his mental instability and it's
basically become one of the defining
features of his character now by now i'm
sure most of you are saying to
yourselves okay yeah that's all well and
good rob but is this guy really beyond
omega level what about deadpool makes
him beyond omega level okay so let's
shut down your argument with a quickness
so just by looking at his powers there's
nothing that leads us to say deadpool is
even near beyond omega level but when we
look at his feats well that's just a
whole different story for instance in
deadpool team up number 883 deadpool
finds himself in dire need of money
largely due to buying over 25 000 worth
of guinea pigs naturally he tries to
find a job by cold calling all the
villains he can think of to see if any
of them need his mercenary services now
all of them end up saying no and just as
it seems all hope is lost deadpool sees
a help wanted out in the newspaper for a
position as a herald now as it turns out
the one who placed the ad was of course
galactus which is cool because galactus
uses craigslist who immediately beams
deadpool up to space and then abuse him
with the power cosmic and in that moment
deadpool is definitively beyond omega
level this brings him into conflict with
galactus former herald the silver surfer
and during their battle deadpool
literally brings an entire star down on
the silver surfer's head while this
doesn't kill the silver surfer the fact
that deadpool is able to wield stars as
weapons and destroy a planet in the
process definitely made him beyond omega
level albeit for a short time because
after his battle with a silver surfer
deadpool resigns from his position as
herald and therefore loses the power
cosmic but that would not be the last
time deadpool became beyond omega level
and deadpool issue number 45 we
basically see him being hired by thanos
to steal the cosmic cube and deliver it
to him now deadpool uses the cosmic cube
to trick thanos and switch the real
infinity gauntlet to being on deadpool's
hand while thanos has a plastic replica
he then uses the gauntlet to blast
thanos helicopter out of the sky and
then decides to use its reality warping
powers to fulfill his ultimate dream
forcing all the heroes and villains of
the marvel universe to hold a toast into
his honor now is this the most
impressive display of reality warping
yeah absolutely it is now eventually
deadpool realizes that he isn't getting
fulfillment out of the toast and undoes
his first meeting with thanos and then
hands the real gauntlet back to him now
we also see deadpool get some major
upgrades to his power during 2015's
deadpool vs thanos miniseries where he
wore what is arguably the greatest
costume in the history of the world
which was basically a afro and a
mustache which he wore over his suit but
in this series both deadpool and thanos
are in love with mistress death and are
made into her avatars to battle the
cosmic entity eternity who is basically
the embodiment of everything in
existence now once given death's power
deadpool is able to punch and seemingly
hurt eternity and while eternity then
swats him away like a fly the fact that
he could hurt the living embodiment of
the universe is pretty impressive now
later as thanos is about to kill
eternity deadpool's visited by the
unipower one of the most powerful forces
of marvel comics who's in need of a host
so that it can save eternity's life
typically the unit power bonds itself to
someone who's worthy and responsible but
there's not really anybody that fits
that description around there so it just
goes with what it has right and it
ultimately turns deadpool into captain
universe now as captain universe
deadpool has cosmic awareness and nearly
limitless power as he serves as the
avatar of life in the universe and in
this form deadpool is able to get the
better version of thanos in battle so
it's pretty obvious that for this moment
in time deadpool was beyond omega level
but believe it or not that's not all in
fact deadpool has killed an entire
universe in the miniseries aptly titled
deadpool kills the marvel universe this
event of course kicks off with deadpool
being committed to a mental institution
by charles xavier and the x-men in hopes
of curing him of his mental instability
the institution turns out to be a front
for the villain psycho man who's trying
to build an army of villains under his
control and take over the world but
after the experiment however deadpool
frees himself from cycle man's control
and then kills him by literally just
bashing him it was hilarious
and then he notices that there is now a
more evil sadistic voice in his head
that had never been there before and he
sets out on a mission you guessed it to
kill everybody in the marvel universe he
starts with a fantastic four and then
he's able to use a cosmic taser that he
stole from reed richards to kill uwatu
the watcher and probably the funniest
moment in the entire series deadpool
then continues his killing spree taking
out spider-man before making his way to
avengers mansion where he uses pym
particles to cause a table to expand so
much that the mansion comes crumbling
down killing all the avengers except for
luke cage and thor but as it turns out
deadpool had planned luke cage's demise
by putting pym particles in his coffee
which he then activated to enlarge his
insides until they burst against his
unbreakable skin and he even manages to
take out thor by using the particles to
enlarge mjolnir and when thor summons it
it crushes him now with the avengers out
of the way deadpool then moves on to the
x-men who he takes out in a variety of
ways including using a carbonation blade
that negates wolverine's healing factor
but deadpool's most impressive feats
during the mini-series unfortunately
occur off-screen or at least off-panel
as we see nova gladiator silver surfer
thanos and galactus all dead at
deadpool's hand although we have no idea
how it was that he managed to do it so
yeah is deadpool as he's typically
written beyond omega level no but there
are certainly moments where he has been
have all those been in continuity well i
mean i guess it really depends on how
you look at it but who cares deadpool is
a character that is known for breaking
the fourth wall and being aware that he
isn't real so does continuity really
matter when we're talking about deadpool
i don't really think so maybe you
disagree i don't know the only thing i
do know is that i'm right with that
being said guys thanks for watching and
i will catch you all later peace